hello everyone and welcome to a very
enjoyable game also from the Roan open
2023 where ala F was able to qualify for
the F candidates tournament by
eliminating everyone uh he won the
tournament with seven out of seven and
we did show that game against gatak
kamsky was a very impressive one but
this one does seem to be a Hidden Gem it
was sent to me by a subscriber joanni
vanelli so thank you for that let's
check it out it's quite an amazing game
uh here he faces a French International
Master Hugo and he makes one slight
sort of an inaccuracy in the opening in
a very well-known line and ala just
takes advantage of that masterfully so
let's check it out alza with the white
pieces opens with Pawn to D4 uh Knight
to F6 we have C4 G6 Knight to C3 and
Bishop to G7 the king's Indian defense
is on the board uh e E4 D6 and now Pawn
to H3 by Ala the So-Cal makono variation
uh we have castles and now Bishop to E3
we have Knight to A6 all standard stuff
nothing new Here pawn to G4 by alza and
pawn to E5 alza closes the center D5 and
now Knight to C5 and usually when you
have a king's Indian defense type game
you will have white attacking on the
queen side with uh with the pushing of
Pawns and black will have some sort of a
king side attack the he he will REM
maneuver the knights both Knights to the
king side play F5 and then start pushing
but here all is as you can see already
has H3 G4 and he's saying that he wants
to be aggressor here we have Pawn to F3
Pawn to A5 and now Queen to D2 signaling
that he might be interested in trading
off the dark Square Bishops and he have
he has his E4 Pawn nicely defended he
played E3 so a similar setup you would
see against a dragon Sicilian we have
Bishop to D7 and this is the inaccuracy
I've um discussed in the opening here
the still position is a very standard
one and C6 can be played but after
Bishop to D7 C6 can no longer be played
and ala shows why he castles Queen side
Here and Now C6 would be a problem if
you played C6 now then just D captures
and the D6 Pawn is hanging so how do you
how do you deal with this well H here
Knight to E8 was played with the idea
that okay now you can play C6 and the D6
Pawn is nicely defended uh but Knight to
E8 does not help you in anyway as the
Knight here was um sort of uh very
important in the defense of the bishop
on D7 and again uh C6 cannot be played L
just starts a kingside attack with Pawn
to H4 and now if you play H6 well
there's the problem of the bishop here
you will just play Bishop captures and
C5 and after d captures D captures and
C6 with the bishop hanging or if you
move the bishop then you just capture on
d8 and you won a full Rook uh so after
H4 uh Pawn to F5 was played a fairly
standard King's Indian maneuver uh G
captures on F5 G captures and Bishop to
a H3 putting pressure on the F5 Pawn uh
we have Queen to C8 uh and now Pawn to
H5 ala just continuous advancing that
Pawn King to h8 and now Pawn to H6 we
have Bishop to F6 and now Bishop
captures an F5 ala trades everything
here and it seems that um okay black is
now doing very well Hugo defended and
ala can't really defend the develop the
Knight as the F3 Pawn would hang H but
that's exactly what alza does he plays
Knight G3 E2 and he sacrifices the pawn
and really uh objectively best is to
capture the pawn uh with something like
Queen captures then Rook D to F1 attacks
the queen but then you have Queen G4 as
the C4 Pawn is hanging but still white
wastes a move and it's still going to be
white who's better uh but it was
definitely the way to go in the game
Rook to G8 was played and now Pawn to F4
ala no no longer offers a pawn now he
wants to trade on E5 and open up this
dark Square diagonal e captures on F4 we
have Knight Capt now also with the
possibility of reaching that E6 square
with the Knight Knight to E4 and here
Queen to D3 the Knight cannot move as
the queen on F5 would hang so Knight to
G3 offering a queen trade and although
it seems like ala should avoid the queen
trade as uh he wants to be the one
attacking he already has a Pawn on H6 uh
Queen trade is objectively best here so
Queen captures Knight captures and
Bishop to D2 uh Rook to G4 putting
pressure on the Knight preparing to
develop this Knight and get this Rook
into the game H but now Knight to E4 and
look at this bishop to D4 with a double
attack on the sorry H not Bishop to E5
Bishop to D4 was played and now alza
plays Knight to E6 and he sacrifices the
knight uh how can the Knight be captured
well it cannot uh it it can and cannot
because it's the strongest move but it
also loses the game so if you capture
the Knight then Rook D to F1 and uh okay
now all res will back the Knight or this
Knight mov moves and then you get
checkmated since the pawn is covering
the king from uh reaching G7 but also
the Knight is doing that as well and if
you try Knight E7 Rook to f8 check and
Knight to G8 then just Knight captures
on D4 and black is pretty much without a
move now of course if you capture Bishop
C3 skewes the rook and black resigns so
here Bishop to E5 was played uh and now
Rook H to F1 putting pressure on the
Knight and again the Knight cannot move
due to Rook to f8 Rook captures an 4 we
have Rook captures on F5 and not even
Rook captures on C4 with check ala gives
up this Pawn with tempo as there there
really isn't a way for black to get out
of all of this um uh tactics here so
King B1 now comes Knight to F6 but now
Rook D to F1 with idea of Rook captures
F6 but also even simpler just Bishop to
to G5 so Knight to G8 and now Rook to f8
completely tying down the black king
Rook captures on f8 and now Rook
captures an f8 so what do you play here
uh Bishop to F6 um here is sort of the
the move that was played uh if you don't
do that um what else can you do Bishop
to F6 was played sort of stopping Knight
to G5 but guess what white played here
feel free to pause the video and figure
out uh how to go about this position
while I give you a couple of seconds
it's a for checkm in five but in in in
you know in reality even
less
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on paying attention
to what I was saying and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is KN to G5 yes that is the move and
here this was played and it was unmoved
32 that Hugo trar resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
the threat is Knight to F7 Checkmate and
unless you don't want to this to happen
you have to capture on G5 but then just
Bishop captures and now Bishop to F6 six
will be Checkmate uh the Knight cannot
move the king cannot move um Rook cannot
go to to to F4 it's covered by the
bishop The Rook cannot go to C1 it's
covered by the king so there is no move
here you you you can you know give up a
piece and survive a few more moves until
the bishop reaches F6 or some other
square but the black king will be
checkmated uh so very nicely done by Ala
and you can see how interesting this
mogon of variation is against the king's
Indian defense this um Pawn to H3 move
and yeah they played it you know
perfectly fine but then this slight
inaccuracy uh that occurred on move 10
after Alles Queen to D2 you have to play
C6 but after Bishop D7 it's already
objectively maybe even lost against a
player like ala so incredible stuff uh
yeah if you want to if you want to play
theoretical openings you have to know
your theory uh what are you going to do
uh but yeah nicely done by Ala we
already covered the game against um uh
the famous Legend if you haven't seen it
check it out first link in the
description below I would like to thank
Carl Weinberg Sergio vinoli an Anna
panovich Robert kefir and Welsh fan for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World the Tata
still is starting soon uh so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your
day